welcome back all right so we're talking
about vector calculus div grad and curl
divergence gradient and rotation of your vector
field today i'm talking about the gradient
okay and notice that i have already gotten too
lazy to include my little over bars i'm basically
going to drop these but we know that this
operator is a vector of partial derivatives so
the grad operator is partial partial
x partial partial y in two dimensions
if in three dimensions there would be a partial
partial z i'm going to make my life easy and for
now just look at it in 2d and the gradient of
a scalar function f so if i have some scalar
f of x and y just recall that the gradient
of f sometimes this is also called grad of f
is a vector field so it takes a scalar and
creates a vector field partial f partial x partial
f partial y so when you hit grad with an f you
literally just put in f here so if i had grad f
there would be an f here and you would apply the
partial partial x to f and the partial partial y
to f and you would have those in the two the two
components of your vector output very simple to
compute we could create an example for example
if f was i don't know x squared plus y squared
then the gradient of f is going to be the
partial of this with respect to x which is 2x
in the first component and the partial of this
with respect to y in the second component to y
and essentially what that's going to do if i plot
that as a vector field in x and y where maybe this
is the origin what we're going to have is as x
and y get bigger this vector field gets bigger
in the x direction so it starts off small in
the x direction and gets bigger and bigger
if i start in the y direction for larger
y it gets bigger and bigger and similarly
on the diagonals the farther i go it gets bigger
and bigger in kind of all of the directions
so very very intuitive easy to compute for
a given scalar function x squared plus y
squared this kind of makes sense because
this function also gets bigger and bigger
as i get higher in radius x squared plus y squared
literally uh is like a big paraboloid if i look
down you know on this kind of x y and if i look
down on that in this x y coordinates it kind of
makes sense that my gradient increases as i go
farther away because this gets steeper and steeper
okay so that's how you compute the gradient
this is kind of mathematically what it is
a couple of interesting properties here the
gradient is a linear operator in fact this nabla
operator this del operator in general is a linear
operator so grad is linear which specifically
means that if i take the gradient of some
function f1 plus another function f2 it equals
the gradient of f1 plus the gradient of f2 and
you can convince yourself that this is true
because basically if i had you know f1 plus
f2 i would take the partial of the sum of them
on in both rows and the partial
derivative is a linear operator so
partial of f1 plus f2 is partial of f1 plus
partial of f2 so you can verify that this is true
and also that the gradient of some constant a
times f is that constant times the gradient of
f so this is really important linearity means that
superposition holds if i write down a differential
equation in terms of the gradient operator it's
a linear differential equation and superposition
will hold if i have two solutions and i add
those solutions there's still a solution when
you add them together so linearity is a really
important property for differential equations and
for operators in general and i just want to point
out that the gradient is in fact a linear operator
okay a couple more examples of the gradient
this is one that i've given you a few timesbut i really like it so
If i take thegradient of a temperature field T(x,y)
and let's say that the temperature
field is going from hotter to colder
Okay let's say, maybe I have a blow torch, andthis is a metal plate, and I hit it with ablow torch for 10 seconds
and then I let it go
so it's hot in the middle cold on the outside
the gradient of this temperature will be
a vector at every point. I will have a grad(T)
and that grad(T) is a vector of partialT / partial x
and partial T / partial y ...
it willliterally have an arrow direction telling me
how fast that temperature changes in the x
and y directions and every point it will point
in the direction of the maximum rate of change
so the gradient of temperature tells me what
direction is locally the fastest way to climb
that temperature gradient. It's kind of why the
name stuck, and so I always like to give a
homework question or an exam question to my
students... and I think they all think I'm crazy
...which is okay... You're an ant flying around ina room and you're cold, or sorry ants don't fly,
you're a bee flying around in a room and you're
cold and there's a heat source, so in what direction
do you fly to get there as fast as possible and
if they have the temperature distribution, all they
have to do is compute the gradient at that bee's
location right now and they'll go towards that asfast as possible
Again, I mentioned earlier this is
how we optimize functions in lots of optimization
problems mathematically is by gradient descent.
I would literally take steps along the gradient
direction until i climb this hill, and that's a
pretty fast, efficient way of finding the optimum
value -- the maximum or the minimum -- of a function
that's how we train machine learning algorithms
like deep neural networks with stochastic
gradient descent.
Exact same gradient. Sometimes it's a bee flying aroundin a room
sometimes it's a billy goat climbing a mountain as fast as possible
that billy goat still computes the gradientof the altitude to climb as fast as possible
okay
good um a few other things i want to point out
you can use this gradient to compute
what's called a directional derivative
so i'll just write that out here
so the directional derivative
um
and essentially the directional
derivative is literally the derivative
the derivative of f my scalar
function f in a direction
v so this is kind of cool we're used to being able
to take the derivative of our function in the x
direction that's just partial partial x we're used
to being able to take it in the y direction that's
partial partial y but what if i say okay take it
in this v direction i've got some random vector
v how do i take the derivative of f the rate
of change of f in that direction is f getting
bigger smaller by how much and mathematically
we say that this is the directional derivative
of f in the v direction this is how
we write it it's the derivative of
f in the v direction and it's super simple
it doesn't get simpler than this it's just v
dotted with the gradient of f remember the
gradient of f is a vector and i can dot it
into this direction v so i literally just see
like where is that where is you know grad t
grad f pointing and i dot it with v and that
tells me how fast and if they're perpendicular
then the directional derivative is zero actually
i kind of drew it so that the gradient is almost
perpendicular to this v in which case
the directional derivative would be zero
which means if i take a small step in that
direction my temperature doesn't change
there are directions like that and you
have to normalize by the length of this
v because someone might give you like a v that's
10 units long or 0.10 units long and it shouldn't
matter what the length of v is so the
directional derivative also super important
okay one more example i want to really like
drive home how much i love the gradient
how useful it is and i feel like when i'm
learning math i like to see it a lot of
different ways because maybe one of them clicks
so the gradient allows me to compute the rate
of change of a scalar field in the x and y
directions that's literally the rate of change
in the x direction the rate of change in the
y direction it allows me to compute directions
of fastest rate of change it also allows me
to take the derivative in any old direction
and uh another example of the gradient beyond
the temperature distribution is uh gravitational
potentials okay so an object maybe i'll do a pink
over here so another application is an object
in a gravitational
field okay and i want to kind of try
to remember how to actually do this so
we have newton's law of gravity
okay and newton's law is something like uh
the force and remember force has a direction it's
a vector the force is equal to um if i have like
i should probably draw a planet
here so if i have planet earth
let's actually make this kind of fancy
right so we got some some continents
really bad at drawing earth okay
we've got some continents over here
earth earth has a gravitational field right
and that gravitational field always points
towards the center of earth we know that
that's true and in fact the gravitational
field is stronger the closer you are if you
go way way out i'll only have a little force
a smaller force okay so it's always pointing
into the center and it's bigger when you're
closer and you can write that down newton's
law as minus little m times big m times the
gravitational constant divided by the
radius cubed times some radius vector
where um how do i wanna say it so that's if i have
some point out here with mass little m of course
earth has mass big m uh and this r vector is
always pointing towards the center of the earth
okay this is always the vector pointing
towards the center of the earth
and this has magnitude r so i need another r down
here we know that the force decreases as r squared
and then i need another r to counteract the
magnitude of this and that's it the force
always points in the radial direction and it
has magnitude given by this expression here
okay that's all fine and good this has
nothing to do with the gradient so far
except that this is a potential field this is
equal to minus the gradient of the potential
energy of this object so any object at some
radius r is going to have a potential energy
and its potential energy increases the farther
out you go in r and literally the gradient of
that potential is what gives rise to this uh this
force law here where the gravitational potential
uh the gravitational potential v is equal to
uh minus little m big m big g over little r um
that's it literally the potential increases as you
as you go farther away and if you grab this object
you arrive at this force law vector field so i
highly encourage you to actually do this exercise
write this out in cartesian xy or xyz coordinates
and compute its gradient and convince yourself
that it is actually the right gravitational
potential okay very kind of useful idea.
This isalso useful if you have a roller coaster on earth.
I love roller coasters... in fact I'm filming this at
7:00 pm the day before I'm about to move
across the country to California for sabbatical...
that's how much I love gradients and
I love teaching you about gradients
and on the way, we're going to go to Santa Cruz and
we're going to ride roller coasters at their fair.
And the exact same potential -- if
I write the potential energy of a car
on a roller coaster, I can create a
vector field of the forces at every point
on that roller coaster, by computingthe gradient. Okay, that's how gravity is acting
on the car at all of those locations.
So this is the gradient... we're gonna do the same
thing for div and curl and then we're gonna start
putting these objects together and showing how
these partial derivatives and
these operators are the building blocks
of vector calculus, conservation laws, and partial
differential equations. All right thank you.